ken
do you believe in magic
no
well you're about to become a believer
cause
black magic is real
[Music]
it wasn't scary
yeah black magic doesn't get scary in
there
okay we're going to check out black
magic blue
let's see if we can get convinced first
we have um there's an algae in the sand
whoa
that is black magic i believe whoa
that's actually sick
whoa
kind of algae does that oh yes
that's so cool whoa it's so bright oh
he's got no way
i bet this is in australia or something
no it feels australian they'd be like
yeah no
that is pretty crazy bioluminescent
algae have you ever experienced that
without when he lights up no i've never
the only thing i've ever seen like this
is when you like rub your feet on the
carpet a lot and you touch someone and
it goes you know that little that little
shock that's all i've ever seen i've
seen this and then you can pull your
hands in the water and if it's like
you're shooting lightning through your
fingers is really cool but i've never
seen it like this this is like next
level god dang now these people like
get radioactive poison or something from
being out here can i can tell that
you're not believing magic is real yet
okay i will convince you with this clip
is that firework who's that i don't know
that's magic
what happened a lightning bolt is guided
to the ground through rocket trail
just the trail is enough to connect so
that rocket exploded
that is cool though what about the
people standing around where the rocky
got launched from was it like a little
family experiment yeah and then they're
all
just fried now what happened to the
family they're doing a little
kid's first pump up rocket or something
wow dad look at that
how about this bmw changing color i
actually seen this it's kind of cool it
is pretty cool
i wouldn't say black magic that is cool
no that's that's dlc for cars because
you know how bmw's charging micro
transactions to get your heated seats
now i've heard about that
like oh yeah you want some colors for
your car well that's going to be an
extra
3 000
but i gotta have the platinum shine
it looks just like white but it's kind
of
i feel like this is like a gta move when
you're running from the cops
he's chase the color of your car genius
yeah
it doesn't feel like a bond movie thing
it is kind of sick i i
yeah but not magic even i'm not sold on
this one all right what about this man
does he know magic
so far i'm not impressed top interesting
that was awesome
all right all right
there's a string ken
you can see i can see the rope on the
ground
down here i mean there's a giant rope on
the ground i don't know if that has
anything to do with it
that's pretty cool though
explain it then if you don't if it's not
magic can you have to explain it
well you see it's spinning so fast
like in an anime you know when they spin
real fast they just kind of like flop in
the air yeah that's what it's doing you
know it's it's
aerodynamics
or something or that red thing on the
ground
there's a ghost it's the ghost of his
dead wife she did it
so magic not real ghost real got it okay
did i tell you about the uh the
restaurant i went to not long ago where
they had like a magician that was just
walking around doing card tricks i love
that it was pretty nuts i i was like
thinking it would be like just some like
really easy tricks no it's cooler when
it's in your face yeah i've done this in
japan too it was sick what did they do
uh well like he did the one where he's
like pick a card and you like show the
card and then he's like you know think
about true love and give it a kiss and
like your card is red in the deck and
he's like is this your card like yeah
that's it and then he puts it under like
someone else's hand he's like okay you
hold that card and then he gets you to
pick another card and then he can't find
it in the deck he's like oh where is it
oh it's under the person's hand the
whole time and i was just like
all right
maybe i believed in magic at that point
a little bit he also stopped the card
and get you to sign the card and he like
eventually spits it out like in his
mouth and you're like that's cool okay
covet and everything cool
they did the same thing for me where i
signed the card and then it was inside a
water bottle that was closed shut oh
that was pretty impressive i was like
damn how do you do that for real and he
let me keep the bottle and i was just
like staring at him like but how did he
do that yeah you check it see if there's
like a slid in and you couldn't find
that one you're like yeah yeah
it was pretty pretty yeah all right
draining a glass for set
i don't know if that is
colossal
whoa is that real
what that looks like 3d rendered
looks like a glitch in the matrix yeah
it does what is that gloss for sag
roundup
freaking
plant poison
hell yeah kill those planes oh
before they dies you sprayed at them
some weird matrix stuff
that's mesmerizing that's cool it's
pretty crazy
well we know it's not magic so i don't
care
all right how about this magic
why is that cloud just chilling there
ken if magic isn't real there's a wizard
on top of that mountain he is charging
himself
yes for a long time it takes a long
cooldown
someone's up there vaping right now
it no magic happening gandalf's up there
just smoking this pipe
the s curve
whoa
[Music]
that's cool he's an airbender
my god
all right we can explain this as well
he's clearly studied airbending
those are magnets and he's shooting a
metal arrow yep
i don't know how magnets work either but
still it's oh yeah it could be magnets i
think about it you're right big magnets
though very expensive
i wonder now i thought it was it was
wiggling the
arrow
yeah it swings itself
pretty cool yeah well i don't know like
if you ever seen like an arrow be a shot
slow motion like it wiggles back and
forth when it flies yeah okay yeah
wow magnet he's magnetic it is magnetic
[Music]
wow
i think i saw one where where they would
like pick an object
and they would just like
charge it up and then they would stick
to the wall
like if it was a corner
huh
just imagine if you were this dude
though like
you're the guy that can stick stuff to
his head
hell
yeah didn't work ken
you tried to stick your foot you stick
your phone to your face i did it
oh yeah yeah i did it you're magnetic
yeah so it's not matching yeah you know
magic automatically i i know how to put
things on top of my glasses i did it
okay the magic bottle okay
what
what
oh
man
[Music]
oh my god it's like toy story it knew it
knew it was being watched
so he went back
oh my god what the [ __ ] is that
what
whoever bowser's gonna be disappointed
i i believe in magic now you have to say
you believe in me
oh this is a classic have you seen this
the time travel dude
look at it look at it
look at it no no no
he's like bro watch out
[Music]
[Applause]
that man is a damn traveler dude he's so
confused
you gotta believe in this time travel
now okay i mean there's there's there's
a religious old lady watching this right
being like this guardian angel right
there yes dave just live can't
the time traveler get hit cuz he's
walking down the street right now
i didn't think of that
oh just like laying there dying
shoot him
shoot him he's a sorcerer shoot him
he knows magic get him get him
whoa
how
where did that come from ken
jeez look at that jesus
yeah
catch the devil man i swear that's why
i'm allergic to them they are freaking
styrofoam
magic again
styrofoam from his magic it's not the
bands it's not the bottles it's the
styrofoam
wireless gas i didn't want to invent it
before i've seen this from like a water
hose it's
yeah this is like a clear hose to it or
something there's no way
bluetooth torch okay that makes sense
isn't it kind of funny though like we
know certain things like that makes no
sense gas cannot just travel yeah right
but then you're like yeah but i can
download all these movies and which
illegally legally of course
i can do that from from like uh uh air
like waves and [ __ ] i can talk to
someone across the world with this box
in my hand right here yeah that's normal
oh it's kind of cool though
oh that's cool
wow
i kind of want to try that out that's
pretty cool the kids will go crazy for
that
[Music]
i got one of those strong lasers
first thing i did was pointing at my
hand
[Music]
do not don't do that he's just like oh
cool a laser
one day you woke up in the star wars
universe you just be like oh what is
this a lightsaber
i keep thinking when i see those women
i'm like someone's gotta have touched
that
how do you how do you resist it only
took one time and they never touched it
again
i i win the darwin award in the star
wars universe
whoa oh it's the the ever burning tree
that's black and magic
what do you wish
well how'd that tree get on fire i don't
know you walk up to the tree and he goes
[Music]
yes master tree
what can i do for you
uh
bigger peepee
and more wishes
oh
[Music]
someone he he blew on it really hard
bruh
why am i not amazed by this how's he not
like even impressed himself he's just
like does that look sad like oh okay
well
okay
why am i amazed if a japanese man puts
my
name in a water bottle but this is just
like i don't know
opening a watermelon that's gonna be
good right with the toothpick
possible they do that too
that's magic right there again
what
how did he do it damn he must be like
one punch man so strong
i gotta try that
oh i gotta show that to marcia later you
gonna try you get a watermelon out and
start thumping it
it's pretty nice oh yeah all right here
it is guys a quick trick because 60
seconds just isn't enough time to do
good magic so look check it out i'm
going to take these scissors here we'll
just give it a quick snip like that then
when we untie the ends of the ropes
we'll end up with two equal and i can
fix this twist it and blow
and of course they stretch into two
equal lengths of rope of course this
trick works best if you blow and just
use one piece of rope completely respect
i think my favorite way to do the trick
is to just pop the ends right off there
you go and that way you have a rope with
no end and of course you have ends with
no rope but it doesn't matter everything
is repairable in the end and if i just
take the ends of the rope and put them
in my pocket like that i can give it a
snap we get one end two ends and of
course
the middle and that's got to be worthy
of all i can share because your boy's
shadow band
right on tick tock
what do you do
magic was he doing to get shadow band
the dark magic
tick tock knows something about this man
oh my god
this is magic goats have magic powers
100
cannot tell me other way
what's that they're just climbing this
wall
yeah they got them demonized too
they've made packs with the devil
they definitely middle makes sense
how do they not getting anxiety if i
stood up there like that
can you imagine if like
animals all felt like humans do and just
sitting around with anxiety
oh god let's see if i fall it's getting
hurt so bad
my existential dreads kick again
oh i seen this this is cool
i want that
metal gear i want
otaka i think i won they have the
technology
i can see his
still it's hands
impressive you know
you know what
i feel like i could invent an
invisibility club
why do you feel like you could do that
just put cameras
an algorithm algorithm
with the powers of camera and ai you can
make an invisibility cloak
yeah i feel like it should be possible
frozen legs always magic
he just called the deep one
loch ness mom's about to bust up at that
lake
can i talk
yeah record this but don't say anything
that was the best part
now
you're doing the video what are you
doing
ever walked across a frozen lake before
yeah i'm swedish what do you think i
know i've never even seen well no i've
seen a frozen like one time in my whole
life
really yeah
yeah did you walk across no it like
heart it barely ever snows where i grew
up at and so the fact that the lake was
frozen one time that's a death trap just
waiting to happen whoever walked on that
definitely died i'm not too sure if
anybody did when people fall into eyes
and they like lay there for a long time
and then they wake up that's black magic
they find like a dog frozen in ice one
time
and they just like came up and it was
totally fine like what the [ __ ] that's
black magic that is black maybe i
thought you like brain damage or
something you know you just guess you
can't tell on the dog
okay okay that's my okay that's magic
ken you can't say that's not i look like
i'm naked
my shorts are so high um
[Laughter]
that's magicking it's it's say you
believe in magic it's a symbiote it
needs to go back to
the
hive whoa he works anywhere
wow
hey it's going back to its people
that not that far is impossible no way
whoa i think we can conclude here kane
magic is real
yeah yeah we can smash like if you
believe in science subscribe if you
believe in magic and you can win five
million dollars and you win you get five
million everyone does maybe
some people do lottery that some people
might win i will say that everyone
could possibly
maybe
not because you subscribed to course but
possibly just in your lives hey i'm not
i'm not i will not disclose exactly the
detail but one requirement yes
it's like you subscribe right now and
subscribe to ken as well thank you for
watching